what's up homie for real though guys
good
you know I'm saying shout out to
everybody all over the world doing a
thing it's stuff like that you know I'm
saying I'm sitting here training no days
off you know I mean now like my boy
Burke getting all fat and shit on
cholesterol medication fuck that shit
I'm out here like crazy Lopes putting it
down everyday shots crazy Lopes you know
I mean I saw this video you got the
moves homie
I seen you Scott punches every dick man
I just want to give you a challenge
video you know why don't you and I you
know step in the brain and shit you can
show me some of your moves we can sell
tickets we could donate them to charity
we could look into winner-takes-all man
you know I know you're the expert but I
thought it'd be fun we can do a lot back
yeah shit like that
shout out to just t-nuts putting it down
like a beast Rock I'm going to do some
weight resistance cock punches right now
inspire but crazy looks